en el vídeo anterior vimos cuál es la
mínima rapidez necesaria para mantenerse
en este ruta circular que estamos viendo
acá que es de 27 puntos 6 kilómetros por
hora lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo
es y de hechos estoy mostrándoles la
parte de vídeo donde solamente se ve el
pse donde ese es el rizo quiero calcular
la velocidad promedio y voy a usar este
editor de vídeo para ver el tiempo que
tarda en completar esta ruta oeste rizo
y usarla para calcular la distancia de
asumiendo que esta forma es circularon
que realmente se ve más como de nuevo
para poder calcular la ruta
y el tiempo la distancia que recorre
este
auto y ver la velocidad que tiene veamos
el vídeo
este es un programa llamado firmware del
reino unido- y aquí está el rizo lo
vemos de nuevo
y aquí tenemos un contador
tenemos lo que es los segundos
y en esta sección tenemos cuadros por
segundo no son segundos tenemos 30
cuadros por segundo comienza en 0
segundos 0 cuadros y cuando terminan
llega a 2 segundos y 14 cuadros que son
un 14 sobre 3 14 30 años de segundo
entonces el tiempo que tarda son dos
segundos y 1430 vos casi dos segundos y
medio vamos a escribir esto entonces el
tiempo y eso es aproximado como les digo
no tenemos los datos exactos el tiempo
es igual a 214 a bus 14 30 2 de segundo
aunque la distancia bueno asumiendo que
eso sí vimos círculo perfecto aunque
bueno sabemos que no tiene esa forma en
la distancia es la circunferencia en
este círculo la circunferencia es igual
a 2 pi por radio y de estos piel radio
que encontramos en el vídeo anterior o
que calculamos era de 6 metros así que
dos por seis metros igualaron 2
metros 12 metros
si queremos calcular la velocidad por un
medio
recuerden que bueno la velocidad sigue
cambiando pero la magnitud se mantiene
si queremos ver la velocidad promedio o
rapidez promedio vamos a escribirlo aquí
velocidad promedio
es igual a
2.12 pi metros que es la distancia entre
el tiempo el tiempo que se tardó es de
22 14 30 bosch de segundo
esa es nuestra rapidez
promedio vamos a calcularlo 2
vamos a limpiar esto 12 por pin metros
entre 2 + 14 entre 30
y cerramos nos da
15.28 metros por segundo vamos a
redondear lo es aproximadamente la
rapidez promedio
15.3 metros sobre segundo que es casi el
doble de la velocidad mínima que
calculamos en el vídeo anterior de la
velocidad mínima necesaria para
mantenerse en ruta circular
y esto bueno es bueno es bueno aunque
tampoco queremos ir muy rápido por las
fuerzas que que nos pueden afectar
pero bueno esta cantidad es muy muy
buena si queremos encontrar los
kilómetros por hora vamos a tener que
tomar esa cantidad le vamos a
multiplicar por
3.600 y lo dividimos entre 1000
esto lo dividimos entre 1000
y nos quedan 55
kilómetros por hora
si quieren hacerlo en millas lo dividen
extra entre 1.6 y son 34 millas por hora
más o menos aproximadamente
anotamos aquí aproximadamente
55 kilómetros por hora
aquí hicieron su tarea este con antes
habilidad porque realmente hicieron un
buen margen en la velocidad necesaria
para mantener la tracción en las ruedas